die flammen fressen sich immer weiter
durch kalifornien mehr als 3000
quadratkilometer sind betroffen und es
ist kaum eine besserung in sicht
es herrschen extreme temperaturen um die
40 grad celsius heftige winde fachten
die flammen immer wieder an
in den vergangenen tagen gab es fast
10.000 blitzeinschläge die mindestens
367 neue brände auslöste
seit dem 12 august wüten in dem
bundesstaat insgesamt mehr als 560 feuer
normalerweise haben wir in
südkalifornien diese feuer nicht vor
september oktober november
es ist sehr heiß und trocken aber mit
den einsatzkräften die wir hier vor ort
haben versuchen wir das feuer in den
griff zu bekommen und so schnell wie
möglich zu löschen
fast 120.000 menschen mussten aus ihren
häusern in sicherheit gebracht werden
doch erstaunlich wie gelassen manche
reagieren
zu diesem zeitpunkt leben wir nur noch
in einer dichten rauchwolke die weiteren
in dieser ging hatten einige natürlich
alles leben und nicht nur die hitze
macht der feuerwehr probleme die brände
rund um san francisco und los angeles zu
bekämpfen
aufgrund der korona pandemie sind
feuerwehrleute nur eingeschränkt im
einsatz